- I wanna hear, you were
caught drinking in a picture--
- Oh.
- Behind Miss Adele.
- We were at the Grammy Awards,
and you know, they were--
(audience laughing)
- Look at Adele, she's just
like, "Who am I next to?"
She is like, "What the hell, who's that?"
- It was like, we were
on a commercial break,
right, you know?
- Yeah, the camera's were
off, or so I thought,
and they were on a commercial break
for the Grammy Awards, and
I'm like, here's my chance.
(group laughing)
- Jimi, the problem with the Grammys,
they don't let you drink at the Grammys,
really.
- And it's long!
- And it's long, and so
I think they're afraid
of everyone getting saucy, and so--
- But really, that's golden television.
- Yeah, yeah, there
- There are certain
people who sneak things
- I don't know any of those people
- I don't either